and magnus wow magnus going for this
interesting i think it's not magnus
going for it it's story going for it no
no no of course yeah but this is the
line that has recently been
okay let's take it slow so magnus plays
d4 knight f3 knight c3 this position
which he's had a ton recently
and tariq goes for this line that
recently wesley so has
been playing pawn to e4 and just d takes
e4 here
and peter you probably know this but if
you let your
lila 0 run in the position after
knight c3 c5 after knight c3
um then after a little thinking time
will give this exact
line for black width like zero zero
seven evaluation
like we'll give c5 first move cd5 cd4
24 ed5 e4 d e4 that's what has come to
lila
no more excitement you just get rid of
all the pieces directly and you say
equal
yeah well actually i i didn't know this
i mean usually i'm getting to a position
and then i start to use lila but not
not right from the very beginning ah
that's the difference i just
in the in the starting position i
switched it on show me the way
and this has been the way recently yeah
well
actually it's it was very very funny
because when wesley played it
in uh what in this killing yeah it was
the skilling masters killing open
uh of the champions tour he he used it
for some reason you know i i didn't know
this development
and i was kind of suspicious about this
whole stuff that okay why do you do this
and
and is it really good i mean it doesn't
look so good
and then afterwards okay first of all
wesley kept on playing with success and
he kind of blocked magnus in it
okay he did lose one game but then he
also won one which is
actually for this opening i think like a
miracle
that in in two games you you get two
decisive games and uh
one win with white and one with black
and after the
broadcast uh i mean we had after
wesley won the tournament then we had
him in our broadcast and
he was asking my very opinion you know
and it was like
shocking for me that wow wesley leaves
me with so much respect that peter
uh probably you are a big expert on this
line i mean what
what are your thoughts and you know
honestly i
i just never looked at this i mean it's
basically maybe one of the very few
things in
in the whole chess opening history that
i never ever looked at but
before seeing vastly employed i i really
had no clue that this exists
are you happy that such new tabias keep
opening up that even you haven't seen
before
or do you think ugh come on i put in all
this work at some point should be
finished but there's always new nonsense
yeah well i mean it's uh it's more like
i would be more
uh thrilled if if all these new things
will be somehow more
more encouraging and more interesting i
mean this is definitely as vastly cold
it might be a new berlin
and i'm not sure that many of the chess
fans are so happy about this
if if suddenly against d4 there is also
a way like you know you
go immediately for some end game and you
might be able to analyze it
in fact i feel that this position is
much less rich i mean the berlin end
game is extremely rich and very complex
that's basically one of the reasons why
it's uh
so popular and it's kept on playing on
the highest level and also
in different levels but this one i don't
feel that it's so complex yeah it's uh
it looks like suffering but on the other
hand if black
proves that he might be able to to
handle it
and work out all the things and be
precise in the critical moment then
it's it's a little bit unpleasant yeah
it's just move by move
and so tears confirming that actually
from the very starting position
if you switch on your leela zero then
one of the hot
new engines that it gives this very
position
like that's his main line of chess